[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 informations reportages et invités
pour faire le tour de l'actualité locale
voici les titres de ce mardi 10 décembre
nouvelle journée de mobilisation ce
mardi contre le projet de réforme des
retraites manifestation à paris précédés
par quelques actions locales comme ce
matin à guyancourt et dans cette édition
le point pour la journée de demain dans
les transports
85 jeunes récompensés pour leur mérite
le conseil départemental des yvelines
leur a remis des des ordinateurs
portables sont des collégiens du réseau
d'éducation prioritaire ils pourront
conserver ses équipements pour la suite
de leurs études
enfin il va subir ces premiers travaux
d'envergure depuis son ouverture en 1984
à montigny le bretonneux le club le
village fermera ses portes le 21
décembre pour un an de travaux un
chantier d'envergure plus de six
millions d'euros pour moderniser
l'ensemble à suivre dans ce journal
également reviendra sur cette conférence
organisée par cinq collectifs cantine
sans plastique samedi à louveciennes et
puis deux semaines après la fin du
grenelle des violences conjugales
le témoignage d'une femme victime des
coups de son ex mari elle est
aujourd'hui hébergé par une association
[Musique]
nouvelle journée de mobilisation contre
le projet de réforme des retraites à la
veille des annonces du premier ministre
edouard philippe 180 mille manifestants
selon les syndicats ont défilé à paris
27 mille selon le cabinet indépendant
occurrence un cortège composé
d'organisations yvelinoise la cgt avait
par exemple affrété à cinq bus pour
l'occasion avant de se rendre sur le
lieu de la manifestation à paris des
actions locales ont eu lieu aussi
exemple avec ce rassemblement ce matin
devant les locaux de l'université
versailles saint quentin et guyancourt à
l'appel d'une interorganisations une
quinzaine d'étudiants de professeurs et
de personnel de l'établissement étaient
mobilisés contre le projet de loi est
aussi pour dénoncer la précarité
étudiante ces personnes se sont rendues
ensuite elle devant l'ufr des sciences
de la santé à montigny le bretonneux où
lui est ce qu voté son adhésion en tant
que membre à l'université paris saclay
les propos sont recueillis par nickel et
demi d'euros et patrick jacques de
dixmude la fonction publique est
directement impactée par ce projet de
réforme puisque j'ai activement sur le
calcul des pensions va y avoir une
différence très importante qui est
estimé à au moins 20% par rapport au
système actuel est que
par ailleurs nous
on subit aussi un projet de loi de
transformation de la fonction publique
qui va complètement redéfinir les
modalités de représentation mais aussi
le principe les missions du service
public à d'autres actions au niveau
local se sont déroulées hier
électriciens et gaziers ont par exemple
couper l'électricité pendant deux heures
à la préfecture et à l'hôtel de police
de versailles et des perturbations
encore à prévoir avec quelques petites
améliorations pour la journée de demain
mercredi 11 décembre le trafic de la
ligne u reprend très partiellement son
trafic sa circulation pardon prévoir un
train par sens toutes les une à deux
heures entre 5h20 et 00h56 pour la ligne
n ça ne change pas par rapport à
aujourd'hui
un train toutes les 30 minutes entre
rambouillet et paris-montparnasse de 6h
à 10h 30 et de 16h30 à 21h30 autant de
trains sur l'axé plaisir grignon m et
sur les créneaux 5h15 à 10h30 et de
16h15 à 22 heures pour les lignes de rer
peu ou pas de changement non plus
prévoyez un train sur deux en heure de
pointe sur le rer à 1 train sur 3 sur le
rer b l'interconnexion est toujours
interrompu en gare du nord
enfin aucun train ne circulera encore
sur le rer c entre paris austerlitz et
les gares de saint quentin en yvelines
versailles rive gauche et versailles
chantiers
à noter que train-train 4,4 tram 4 tram
sur cinq seront assurées demain sur le
t6 qui passe notamment par vélizy et
viroflay et enfin sur le réseau stibus
le trafic est revenu à la normale
aujourd'hui cela devrait se poursuivre
ce mercredi après voiliers a tout de
même avec quelques retards
[Musique]
dans l'actualité du jour aussi on prend
la direction de trappes un forum des
professionnels de l'emploi et de
l'insertion étaient programmées pendant
toute la journée en salle du conseil
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines cette deuxième édition
organisée par la cité des métiers le
département et l'agglomération était
exclusivement réservé aux professionnels
au total 35 stands étaient installés les
interviews collectées par michael et
demi d'euros l'objectif de cette journée
c'est de faire connaître les acteurs du
territoire qui oeuvrent dans le domaine
de l'insertion et de l'emploi pour
permettre de meilleurs prescription et
un retour à l'emploi des personnes
habitant sur le territoire de saint
quentin
ça permet de booster sur tous les
échanges entre les professionnels du
territoire et de fait de mieux se
connaître et donc de mieux accompagner
nos publics qui en ont le plus besoin
au chapitre des municipales il sera
candidat pour un second mandat à bois
d'arcy le maire les républicains
philippe benassaya a lancé
officiellement sa campagne ce lundi 200
personnes habitants et soutiens sont
venus à cette soirée où l'édile a
présenté son bilan et dévoilé quelques
pistes pour son programme
philippe benassaya avait été élu pour la
première fois en 2014 succédant au maire
socialiste claude vulliet toute
l'actualité des élections municipales
2020 à suivre ce soir dans un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 politique présentée par
wilfrid richy sûreté les 78 une
cérémonie de don d'ordinateurs premier
événement du genre organisé hier lundi
par le conseil départemental des
yvelines à versailles la collectivité a
souhaité mettre en valeur des élèves
méritants 85 collégiens issus des
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire ont reçu
des ordinateurs portables qu'ils
pourront garder pour la suite de leurs
études et des élèves de 6e et de 5e de
collèges de carrières sous poissy
chanteloup-les-vignes limay
mureaux mantes-la-jolie sartrouville ou
encore à trappes
écoutez ces témoignages de micro de
manon varaldo pour choisir les enfants
nous nous en sont adressés directement
aux principaux des collèges concernés
on leur demande de choisir les élèves
particulièrement méritants que ce soit
par leur comportement leur participation
à la vie citoyenne par leur progression
les élèves qui méritent d'être
récompensés encourager je suis content
et on m'a dit j'ai du jus méritait donc
je suis encore plus contente
dans ces cas-là et bas qu'il ya des gens
qui pensent à nous quand on fait tourner
tous nos efforts j'ai bien travaillé de
ce soit je vais faire des exposés et ça
va mettre beaucoup m'aider pour l'année
prochaine et pour mon avenir je suis
choqué je pensais pas cette année que
j'aurais eu sur kadima
ce à quoi le département a répond qu'il
s'agit avant tout d'un outil de travail
faisant partie de l'éducation numérique
c'est don d'ordinateurs pour les
collégiens elle devrait se poursuivre à
raison de deux cérémonies par an cinq
collectifs s'unissent pour informer sur
la dangerosité du plastique le plastique
du poison dans nos assiettes une
conférence organisée samedi dernier à
louveciennes et pour parler de cette
conférence revenir sur cet événement
deux invités mélanie toussaint bonsoir
et christelle votre un bon soir alors
vous êtes de membres du collectif
cantine sans plastique de louveciennes
le rendez vous était organisée avec
d'autres collectifs cantine sans
plastique ceux de croissy sur seine
saint germain en laye chatou et
levallois perret dans le département des
hauts-de-seine et déjà rappelons ce
qu'est un collectif sans plastique
collectif cantine sans plastique
le collectif quand il sent plastique
c'est une c'est un regroupement de
parents d'élèves tout simplement avec
des compétences et surtout un engagement
fort pour la santé des enfants
voilà il nous a paru important de former
un collectif sur l'ancienne au vu des
problématiques rencontrées dans les
cantines temps à la crèche que dans les
écoles de notre ville alors si on fait
un point sur la législation la loi et
galim qui est porté notamment par la
députée lorien rossi que vous receviez
lors de cet événement cette loi proscrit
le plastique dans toutes les étapes de
la restauration collective de la crèche
à l'université est ce que elle est
totalement appliquée alors l'application
est prévue pour 2025
c'est ça en tout cas on est dans un
processus en vue elle est applicable en
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut cesser le
travail commence dès maintenant parce
que on sait que la toxicité de ces
perturbateurs endocriniens qui sont
contenus dans le plastique et qui
migrent dans les aliments elle est
avérée
donc c'est bien pour ça que la loi a été
a été
édité et qu'il faut la mettre enfin les
marchés sont maintenant donc c'est
maintenant qu'il faut se mettre en ordre
de marche en fait alors je précise juste
par rapport à ce qui s'est affichée vous
êtes bien christelle vautrin et non
mélanie toussaint mais là n'est que ça
et à gauche voilà juste une petite
précision
du coup pourquoi s'unir là il y avait
cinq collectif réuni samedi pourquoi
s'unir contre le plastique justement
mais l'année tout ça alors pourquoi
parce que en fait on est des collectifs
de parents souvent peu nombreux regarde
de tous les parents concernés dans les
communes avec les enfants scolarisés et
on nage on porte une voix mais parfois
les arrête pas assez porté donc on a on
a décidé de former une coalition pour
porter la voix sur la même problématique
parce qu'en fait on a les mêmes
problématiques dans ces communes dans le
78 et à levallois dans le 92 sur les
barquettes en plastique ou du
bioplastique puisque ce sont aussi des
barquettes en plastique et donc les plus
les problématiques de migration des
perturbateurs endocriniens dans
l'alimentation de nos enfants ça l'a
jugée non j'ai sur lesquels vous devez
la vérité c'est qu'il ya des
perturbateurs endocriniens
voilà donc dans ces plastiques la
problématique de ces parcs est qu'ils
sont servis dans nos communes donc c'est
l'industrialisation aussi de préparation
des repas au sein d'unités de production
plutôt que de cantine centrale et qui
utilise la liaison froide se dédire
l'abaissement température des
préparation de repas et de préparer dans
des barquettes stockés dans des
barquettes et réchauffer dans les
barquettes dans les cantines satellite
en tout cas sur le lieu de restauration
des enfants en fait on avait les mêmes
problématiques
on a les mêmes problématiques et du coup
on a jugé utile de porter la voix de
façon plus forte en se réunissant samedi
dans une conférence publique
alfie ciel et l'idée c'est aussi dire
qu'il ya des solutions des solutions de
remplacement aux plastiques c'est ça
qu'elles sont telles que comment peut-on
supprimer totalement le costume
matériaux inertes
essentiellement au line up c'est le vert
en fait parce que ce que ce qui est dans
mii dans la loi aussi c'est que c'est
les plastiques de toutes origines en
fait qu'ils sont à proscrire aussi bien
d'origine pétrolière que d'origine de la
biomasse à base de cellulose est
toujours une couche de plastique pour
refaire l'étanchéité donc s'est présenté
comme une solution par les industriels
ces barquettes de cellulose mais ça n'en
est pas une en fait c'est vraiment
l'inox et le verre qui sont à
privilégier et plus particulièrement les
inox pour tout ce qui est aliments
réchauffer et pour les biberons par
exemple ce serait plutôt du verre
est ce que d'autres actions sont prévues
peut-être des actions de prévention
notamment à des actions de prévention
c'est vrai qu'elles sont difficiles à
mettre en oeuvre à notre échelle et on
voudrait vraiment que les pouvoirs
publics fassent quelque chose ne
serait-ce que dans les maternités pour
proscrire les biberons en plastique et
parler des biberons en verre
les gens ne sont pas forcément informés
des dangers de ces perturbateurs
endocriniens parce que ces barquettes en
plastique qu'elle soit en plastique pet
ressources et ou de la biomasse
elles sont partout les dangers sont
partout et et nos enfants et
particulièrement dans la 3 0 3 ans sont
très sensibles à ces molécules toxiques
donc il est temps d'agir maintenant agir
maintenant merci d'être venu en parler
en plateau on retrouve toutes les
actualités sur le collectif sans
plastique collectif cantine sans
plastique au niveau france sur son site
internet qui s'affiche aussi une page
facebook un pour l'antenne de lucienne
qui existe merci à vous deux cavaliers
tous les autres collectifs du 78 si nous
entendons très bien merci mélanie
toussaint merci avec christelle vautrin
je rappelle que vous êtes membre du
collectif cantine sans plastique de
lucian est depuis le début de l'année en
france 140 de féminicide ont été
perpétrés un phénomène que souhaite
endiguer le gouvernement il organisait
le premier grenelle des violences
conjugales qui s'est achevée il ya deux
semaines parmi ces femmes victimes de
violences certaines ont osé briser le
silence parler des sévices qu'elle
subissait et nous avons rencontré l'une
d'elles
elle est hébergée aujourd'hui et et des
cachets par une association oeuvrant en
ile de france mathilde et demi pour les
moyens techniques
bonjour simone merci nous accorder cet
entretien est de nous partager votre
témoignage vous avez été victime de
violences conjugales pendant cinq ans
avant d'en parler une ancienne vie un ex
mari que vous avez aujourd'hui quitté
vous êtes accompagné hébergé au sein
d'une association qui oeuvre dans la
région parisienne auprès des femmes
battues on va parler avec vous de votre
parcours du déclic aussi qui vous a fait
sortir du silence et aussi de vos
craintes actuelles
déjà si on revient sur votre histoire
votre histoire aussi avec votre ex mari
quand a débuté votre relation avec votre
ex mari et comment a débuté justement
cette relation s'est commencé à tomber
qu'en 2014 à l'étranger et il est venu
demander mariage c'est ses parents qu'il
m'a demandée mariage pendant deux fois
j'ai choisi jusqu'à la troisième fois ci
me prévenir mes parents proposent de
essayer de le rencontrer lui faire
connaissance avec lui
effectivement on
la rencontre entre 2015 et qui ont
dressé en france comment s'est déroulé
le début de la relation est ce que les
coûts sont apparus dès les premiers mois
où finalement ça met du temps à
apparaître
ça va mais je commence à brader chose
que c'est pas normal que d une demande
de beaucoup de choses que j'ai pas le
droit il faut que tout le temps je
demande son interrogation l'autorisation
de sang de ses parents pour faire les
choses sama ça m'a étonné mais si c'est
parce qu'on a discuté à l'étranger c'est
pas ça qui m'a promis bas après j'ai
tomber enceinte
combien ça commence petit à petit et
c'est à des violences mais c'est pas
physique mais mentalement donc c'est
d'avoir de la violence psychologique il
fasse avant de se traduire par de la
violence physique
oui
le message du coach marchi et le jeu que
j'ai sorti de l'hôpital c'est la
première fois qu'est tu sais ça c'est la
première fois que je récitais des
violences physiques
c'est là qu'il ya eu les premières
violences physiques vous le disiez juste
auparavant vous ne vous sentiez pas
libre c'est ça le sens d'une nouvelle
autorisation pour que je te demande
d'être les héros du tout et il oublie il
a le droit de faire tout ce qu'il veut
de vivre sa vie comme il veut mais mais
respecte pas notre relation qu'on est
marié avec 10 coups là elle est encore
libre
par contre au moins j'ai de sentiers qui
sait comme des 1/4 à je peux pas je peux
rien faire sans demander son
intervention et tout est rationnée
sépare nous aviez l'impression et vous
sentir en cas je vous l'avais dit pour
les premiers les premières violences
physiques elles sont apparues après la
naissance de votre fille bowie et désire
rester à l'hôpital de jour et le jour
que j'essaie de la paix table je rentre
à la maison
ça la première jusqu'au premier jour que
marc qui m'attaquent
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti à ce
moment là j'ai rien senti et j'ai fini
ma vie tout ça j'arrive pas j'arrive à
rien faire il était faible et j'ai parce
que j'ai cochon scénario j'aimais pas la
force qu réagir il m'a donné j film à
pau ces choses kaloum c4est et les
couverts et à ce moment là vous vous
dites que
ces violences ne se reproduiront pas ce
que vous allez peut-être cherché à lui
trouver des excuses
quel a été votre état d'esprit on ne vit
pas sur ses excuses mais j'ai essayé de
faire quelque chose je dis c'est bon on
arrête là moi je rentre à l'étranger non
plus pas plus mais mes parents
mes parents ils ont rien faire parce que
songe à dire même le téléphone a coupé
le contact dans la plupart usa et donc
ses coups ils ont duré pendant cinq ans
cinq ans de vie violent cinq ans de peur
aussi puisque vous avez craint pour
votre vie oui parce qu'on a passé
plusieurs fois je sais c'est capable à
sa famille n'est capable de me faire mal
ça je mens tu avais vu un déclic ça
arriver cette année en 2019 qu'est ce
qui te s'est produit qu'est ce qui a
fait que vous avez osé parler osé briser
le silence
justement j'ai commencé
quand je commence à travailler le
travail ça va ça me donne un petit peu
courage et commence à parler avec les
jours mais dominé 19 mois de juillet oui
il ya des violences qui m'a tapé avec la
porte de la voiture dans la rue et c'est
le maire qui m'a trouvé par cas dans le
cas là je crois c'est lui qui m'a
encouragé
c'est en fait c'est pas lui est parvenue
mais c'est la cheffe de la cabine qui
m'a donné un numéro et la plaine
associations et j'ai rencontré
l'association est aussi pendant que
j'étais dans l'ambulance si un policier
qui qui monte dans l'ambulance mais dit
madame il faut porter plainte parce que
s'il faute il d'envoyer leurs pétales la
prochaine phase cimetière mais vous en
avez parlé vous avez porté plainte
du coup ça a été c'était quoi pour vous
c'est un soulagement
à ce moment là qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti mais j'ai pas porté plainte
pas tout de suite pas tout de suite
parce que j'étais pas et on m'a dit
c'est ma menace il m'a dit si tu portes
plainte je veux tu perds ce qu'on va
trouver encore ça intéresse et tepr même
porté plainte j'arrive pas à jeter faire
ça se fait pas peut-être 128,20 le prend
dans mon boulot quand je sortis
l'association des bergers et j'ai porté
plainte
et donc là ça fait deux mois c'est ça
que vous êtes hébergé par cette
association qui avons
[Musique]
en ile-de-france où qu'est ce que ça
vous apporte justement d'être
accompagnés des traits départ par une
par une association
je suis rendu compte et protège ses
protégés et je sens dit qu'il ya des
gens qu'ils soient en avant c'est quand
même je vous dit tout à l'heure j'ai
senti comme chez non cage
maintenant je sens comme mais quelqu un
qui al hemali mur et essayer de tourner
apprendre à voler qu'est-ce que vous
avez encore peur aujourd'hui oui la peur
mais c'est pas comme c'est pas comme
avant sipa commencer quoi justement vos
peurs aujourd'hui on peut ajouter c'est
ma fille parce qu'il menace toujours de
prendre les enfants et de partir avec
l'étranger parce qu'on m'a fait peur
maintenant et pour terminer cet
entretien mais ce que vous avez un
message adressé à des femmes qui qui
sont aujourd'hui dans la situation à
laquelle vous avez été c'est à dire
d'être d'être battue de subir des
violences et de ne pas en parler c'est
ce que vous avez un message à leur
adresse il faut parler il faut prendre
le courage de parler c'est porter des
choses qui ne sont pas c'est pas normal
parce que plus qu'on ne supporte plus
qu'on risque de perdre notre pays il ya
des gens qui sont là pour nous qui pour
ne citer qu'eux
accompagné prend le courage c'est à la
peur mais toujours mon courage de parler
merci pour ce témoignage on rappelle ce
numéro des coudes gratuit et anonyme le
39 19 ouvert sept jours sur sept est
désormais 24 heures sur 24
une balade urbaine au coeur de saint
quentin en yvelines plusieurs habitants
se sont donné rendez vous samedi matin
salle léo ferré à montigny le bretonneux
pour cette marche exploratoire
ils ont pu faire remonter avis et
remarques sur l'hyper centre ce secteur
autour de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines l agglomération et la ville
iny monteyne ont lancé une concertation
pour la rénovation de ce quartier
achevée en 1987 est aujourd'hui
vieillissant l'idée est de le rendre
plus attractif et plus lisible écoutez
les objectifs au micro de mathilde et
demi l'objectif principal c'est
redynamiser ce secteur
renforcer son attractivité en gros la
démarche c'est de s'appuyer sur la
qualité du secteur en confortant ses
caractéristiques environnementales et
naturel rien inventé et travailler sur
l'attractivité du secteur sachant
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un
environnement très concurrentiel en
terme de deux commerces et puis traiter
toutes les problématiques d'identité et
d'image de quartier et les continuités
avec fonctionnel spatiale avec tôt les
quartiers environnementale des ateliers
créatifs et des réunions seront
également au programme de cette
concertation les marchés les festivités
autour des fêtes de fin d'année continue
ce week end c'est le département des
yvelines qui organisait ses propres
animations deux jours sous le signe de
noël au coeur du domaine de madame
elisabeth où les produits locaux
occupaient la première place mélanie
poker le domaine de madame elisabeth
avait revêtu les couleurs de la fin de
l'année pour la deuxième année
consécutive le département des yvelines
proposait son comptoir de noël
nous sommes obligés hélas de fermer ces
lieux dans
né parce qu'ils sont aussi des lieux on
travaille c'est pourquoi je souhaite que
progressivement
nous on a eu travailler ailleurs et que
ces lieux donc soit pour tous les
yvelinois j insiste découverte de poney
projections de films d'animation mais
surtout présence d'exposants une
cinquantaine d'artisans et producteurs
étaient présents avec un point commun
ils sont aussi lillois c'est important
pour les gens qu'ils puissent retrouver
des créateurs à des gens qui font
vraiment de la production bien sûr
locales qui permettent aussi de pouvoir
avoir un suivi on puisse retrouver
nous notre clientèle et que les clients
puissent aussi suivre notre travail nous
voir nous revoir on est dans la mode du
locavore et les gens de plus en plus on
nous demande mais où sont vos ruche
comment vous produisez tard ils veulent
se renseigner
ils veulent adhérer à notre concept est
justement il adore et donc du coup ils
achètent et ils sont fidèles
elle cette année près de 12000 personnes
se sont laissées tenter par ce comptoir
de noël encore un peu de patience plus
qu'une quinzaine de jours avant que les
cadeaux se retrouve au pied du sapin
pendant les vacances de noël vous ne
pourrai malheureusement pas vous rendre
dans ce club emblématique des sports de
raquettes à montigny le bretonneux
le village va fermer ses portes à partir
du 21 décembre pour rénovation des
premiers travaux conséquents depuis son
ouverture en 1984 le point sur le
chantier avec marylène iapichino les
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
créé à l'initiative d'un particulier en
1984 puis repris par la municipalité au
milieu des années 90 le club le village
de montigny le bretonneux ferme ses
portes pour être entièrement réhabilité
fermeture le 21 décembre prochain pour
douze mois de travaux prévus l'ensemble
a été repensé dans sa globalité
donc c'est à 7 à la va être complètement
disparaître ce qui va nous permettre
d'avoir ici sur cet emplacement à peu
près l'arrivée donc l'arrivée des
des personnes qui vont et qui viendront
fréquenté le club le village par sept
par ce chemin là et du coup 7,7
l'activité comme tennis et badminton se
retrouvera sur la halle qui sera fermée
donc là le faire mais qui sera ici à la
place des tennis découverts et donc on
retrouvera nos deux terrains tennis et
nos terrains de badminton unal détruites
pour être reconstruite
l'objectif est de moderniser l'ensemble
le rendre accessible aux personnes à
mobilité réduite et l'adapter aux
nouvelles pratiques sportives
vous voyez que c'est quand même une
halle qui est quand même en mode et a
donc il n'y aura pas d'énormes travaux
de réfection et puis surtout une
structure quelqu'un est saine et qui va
nous permettre donc de d'avoir ici une
activité donc haye 3 terrain de futsal
et des terrains de paddle sur cette
superficie extérieur unal flambant neuf
sera installée pourrait accueillir
terrains de tennis et de badminton une
bande végétale restera pour des
activités de plein air type beach volley
et donc voilà ça ça à partie sur lequel
les logements 55 à 60 logements pour
lequel un opérateur sera déterminé avant
la fin de l'été 2020 un investissement
total de 6 faire que 2 millions d'euros
pour la ville le club le village compte
600 adhérents
et puis un mot de football avant de
refermer ce journal le tirage au sort
des 32e de finale de la coupe de france
de football a livré son verdict hier
soir pas de pas de psg pour versailles
ce sera le club de granville qui évolue
en nationale 2 soit une division au
dessus des yvelinois le leader de
nationale iii recevra la formation
normande au stade mont boron le samedi 4
et le dimanche 5 janvier cela reste à
déterminer en début d'après-midi et des
retrouvailles et dix ans après en 2009
versailles avait éliminé granville au 7e
tour de la coupe de france
espérons que cela se reproduise voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi belle soirée à tous sur tv
[Musique]